free le prix mérite a tiré dessus merci
d'écouter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faire son marché aux bruits d'animaux
massacrés dans les abattoirs
c'est l'étrange sensation qu'on eut les
habitués du marché du quai saint-antoine
à lyon ce samedi matin une action
organisée par des militants de
l'association vega d'impact objectif
dénoncer la réalité de l'élevage des
abattoirs jusqu'à l'état l'âge et la
mise à mort quotidienne de plus de 3
millions d'animaux en france que la
viande soit je tends supermarchés
ouvrent en marche et il n'y a aucune
viande heureuse
son finissent tous au même endroit et de
mort prématurée pour convoler
sensibiliser là dessus par une action un
peu chocs et un peu de pédagogie aussi
des militants ont ensuite parcouru les
étals du marché avec des images chocs
d'animaux ensanglanté provoquant des
réactions contrastées chez les passants
certaines personnes nous remercient pour
notre combat n'existe c'est bien que
nous soyons là aujourd'hui et d'autres
personnes sont choqués par les images et
comme ça c'est souvent ils ont tendance
à nous dire que c'est pas la bonne
méthode parce qu'ils sentent agressés
ils se retrouver en dissonance cognitive
face à ces images ça les met très mal à
l'aise
donc voilà certaines personnes rejettent
d'autres d'autres ont simplement curieux
et regarder tout ce qu'on décrit qu'on
projette le discours contient
ils sont à l'écouté je pense que ça on
arrive à passer un message
prochain événement pour l'association
vegan impact le 1er août à marseille
avec cette fois une action prévue devant
une boucherie